but actually another another tiny tiny
star in the West End of London Eddie
Redmayne I was how did you know I was in
Oliver I was in all I was in a
production of Oliver age about 10 or 11
which was directed by Sam Mendes I was
workhouse boy number 46 yes it's like
Sam Mendes remained on my CV even though
I don't think I ever met him until I had
to go to meet him aged 31 for a meeting
as I should probably cross him or no I
do i but yep no I wasn't Oliver but it
was a great moment
can you show was a little bit of your
your was it in the audition you did this
dance you have very very talented
researchers
soon you'll be at the Oscars this will
be like a bad dream okay since this is
my money to you do we need room yeah you
need room oh yeah you can see yourself
you need room okay so will any bit of
the song do no great city not what what
should they be I'll give you music okay
you don't need you're free to sing along
and you how well do you know all of it
you know Oliver no don't drag me into
this please look okay we don't need
music you're good doing it okay okay so
basically the dream was if you were 11
years old and you wanted to be an actor
I feel like everyone in England at some
point played someone in Oliver and I
wanted to be in the gang and I only got
the part of workhouse boy number 43 but
there was I did an audition I still
remember the dance and here's how it
goes ba ba ba bum ba ba ba bum bum
ba-bum ba-bum consti yourself at home
so strong
because a weird bit of me that was
swinging Stephen Hawking doing that
chance it was just very wrong yeah
luckily you'll see the movie after
you've seen that's the ting a movie
before you see that very bad idea
you know who would that your first
crushes and and and I did I loved the
lion king when I was younger and I had a
whiff session with Nala
want you to push it